[Music]
so you wrote this with David and then
also produced it and then starred in it
and that scene where you're being
crushed and like basically like eating a
part in battle did you regret writing
that as you were filming actually there
was one moment where I thought I'm in
real trouble here because you know my
head was filled with the research and
part of the research was that a majority
of the debts at Agincourt could by
drowning
you know drowning in them art and there
was a moment where I got sort of I was
crawling around in the mud it was about
a foot deep and I couldn't get up and
these guys were tripping on top of me
and I was like I could actually be in
trouble here and is it really worth it
it's really worth cuz like it's twice
now that I had those fear just a flash
of fear that I might die on a movie set
and you think god that would be such a
shame yeah people say oh you died doing
he died doing something he loved but I'm
like no nobody should die on a movie set
wait what was the other one oh I was in
a water tank and I had a like a kind of
tethered thing around my neck which we
release I won't talk about the movie ya
know just cuz I don't want anybody to
get okay why they're in trouble yeah
they're not but it was an accident I got
twist around my neck and I couldn't reg
the surface and it was like two seconds
I thought I'm gonna drown in here
oh well beautiful scuba diver time for
that well that's good you also did like
a ton of other stunts in this one which
I think that's not the first time you've
done stunts like this but were you like
teaching Timmy maybe because I think
this is the first time he's had to do
like a physical role yeah and he was
great I mean I look actors all the
actors I know we're not all of them but
a majority of them the moment you give
him the chance to do a fight scene where
it's like they're you given them a time
machine to go back to when they are a
child and they can invite they can kind
of create a hybrid of themself plus the
child that always fantasized about that
stuff so actors tend to really dive into
you know fight scenes and it's really
great watching people kind of go outside
their comfort zone
- if it's new to them and I think it was
that physicality was sort of new to
Timmy but he just like you know those
people like Timmy like a few of the
other guys they tend to just want to
keep rehearsing the fight they want to
keep learning your stuff and it's
exciting noise I like watching people
get on a horse for that first time
that's I'm gonna ask him about this big
dog a friend of mine calls horses a
motorcycle with a brine motorcycle guys
I'm never getting on home he goes why
would I get on a motorcycle with a
Bronco they can like yeah well you talk
about Timmy getting back to like his
childhood which I mean that was like
what five minutes ago because he's like
ridiculously talented at like 22 which I
hate I don't know if you hate it but I'm
like that's just I love hide it I love
there's gonzo and I worked with you know
obviously work with him and Lucas hedges
and it's like mine's much of these kids
having just put it all together so
quickly at such a young age on a world
with the world watching yeah I was I
can't even look at stuff I did when I
was that age anymore
cuz I just be like oh you're doing
alright stop I'm sorry I learn slowly
these guys learned quick well this film
you did a very good job and I guess what
like you talked about the research of it
cuz ya sitting down to write it did you
talk about the Game of Thrones aspects
because like Henry the eighth by Henry
the fifth sorry is having this like
resurgence because of that show too
because people are realizing like
Hundred Years War is based off of it did
you go into any of that no we weren't
really looking at Game of Thrones but we
were also doing research about the true
history and the v it's interesting that
there's a couple of shots that that are
in our battle send the people like
that's just like Game of Thrones it's
like listen we didn't have a spy in the
Edit room of Gavin Thrones though yeah I
mean look I think there's a lot of
people that have an interest in medieval
stories of you know that period where
we're you know wars were you know people
were cut with knives and swords and you
know and and there's something about all
of those stories that have come since
Shakespeare that I think people you know
look back
to Shakespeare I read so many in fact
the reason whatever is sitting here is
because I read a screenplay and I was
like I didn't really like this idea of
this sword and horse movie but God some
of the speeches in an Assad derivative
of Shakespeare plays that I read and it
made me think what if I actually said to
those same studio people how would you
feel if we went off and wrote a version
of Henry the fifth so you know
Shakespeare is the Holy Grail
we looked at you know doing our own
thing with it with deference and respect
you know not intimidating at all if you
like Shakespeare I got this yeah we got
this but what it allowed us to do is
sort of have our own viewpoint on
politics manipulate elements of sheikhs
be mix it with you know our own research
and bring elements of that in and then
take our own artistic license to kind of
shape that into something that we wanted
to say and and and therefore it helped
to not be tethered to a text that was
already there well it's doing quite well
it had the great premiere at Venice and
it's still got great reviews I think
last time I checked you guys were 77 on
this fall really yeah that's good so I
will say this though you have another
film coming up or bright too which is
the sequel of bright yeah and that's a
film that didn't have the greatest
tomato meter but people loved the movie
including people on our website you're
obsessed with it which is one of the
reasons why we wrote this book called
rotten movies we love the editorial
staff of Rotten Tomatoes people like
Leonard Maltin and David Erlich and all
these really fancy critics and then
people like myself to write about rotten
movies that we love and so like I wrote
about like Harlem Nights or you like
center stage and stuff so what's a
rotten movie that you love that you if
you could like write 500 words about to
be like you guys got this one wrong
that's a really good question well
actually you know I and this is not even
just made kind of you know going oh yeah
defending my bro but it sort of is he
made a movie called gringo which which I
was like okay I don't think this is
going to like sweep the field it's not
going to be like be Irishmen and get a
hundred percent of rotten tomatoes which
I die and I say by the way but but it
almost felt to me like there was
something so original in
casting that movie and and the nature of
that film that I was like really there's
there's a little bit too much hate sort
of slung towards this movie and I think
that maybe there's there's a tipping
point I think sometimes where a certain
amount of reviewers I think jump on a
train together and the thing that makes
me upset about reviewing is not like
whether you get negative or you know
negative reviews it's when journalists
it feels to me like they all go alright
we we're doing that thing where we
regarding replace we relax our creative
writing muscles because filmmakers are
human beings that fit that haven't ego
and and they put a lot of effort into
something and I think very constructive
like be negative but don't ridicule
because that to me is sort of bullying
and they're very clever reviews and they
are fun to read if you if you want but
at the same time I just sit there I go
how do you feel if this was written for
you and have you ever gone out and made
a movie before and like me you should
make a movie before you start like razor
cutting people in the kidneys is all
that used to read the reviews my best
thing I always say to it is it takes an
extreme amount of effort and like
everyone doing everything they can to
make a bad movie imagine the miracle
that it takes to make a good one
exactly
I need men around me I can trust
because you know my friend Kim gets
enough friends kidding
that's only follows that fell will come
woody they even have to start with you
because when you and Joel sat down you
basically said I can write better than
Shakespeare so like Joel and I wanted to
tell a story of Henry the fifth thing
because of his great love for the
players and you know having performed
them on stage when he was a young man
now he's an old man but you know kind of
working out very quickly that we wanted
to make them our own you know both in
terms of form but also in terms of you
know what the movies about wanting
unlike the you know really unlike the
Shakespeare players want to tell a story
of a young King kind of being thrown
into a job with great intent but kind of
coming to realize that the job is so
much bigger than he is and so we we knew
very early on that it wasn't that we
thought we could ride it better it's we
knew that we wanted to do it differently
no I know I was just making he was
literally like yeah no no it's great
because you guys reinvented things like
but Henry the fifth speech is so iconic
and so many people think about it I
think you guys definitely took that
Agincourt speech and really did it up
and then you got to scream it there for
like ten minutes so I think that's like
every young actors exactly yeah no I'll
say that David before of you know this
is down to the title of the movie this
is like the you know bordering on absurd
you know a dream you have when you're a
young guy yeah young anyone trying to
pursue a career in acting as do this
kind of role okay what was that like
that day like what did you do it like
with that throw because that seems like
a long day of yelling like I don't think
I would have been hey we did it we
didn't like we'd like 12 or 15 takes or
something and you know the idea of that
is first and foremost that there's a lot
of you gonna reach the guy in the back
in the back of the back of the troops
and it was exhilarating yeah I mean I
had
words down but I hadn't been like
shouting in my hotel room or anything
trying to get it right so there's
nothing they could prepare you nor do
you want to jump the gun on what it's
gonna feel like to be in front of
hundreds of guys I wasn't even until the
die actually that I suddenly I was
suddenly grateful for the fact that I
had like you know not just an incredibly
talented young actor but an incredibly
trained young actor because it wasn't
till the day that I just you know take
one hit it and go oh man I need to be
careful here that he's not gonna I
wouldn't if I was doing that I'd be dead
I'd be dead halfway through the first
the LaGuardia suitable school my oh but
back to your casting on this one you
made it a pretty Aussie affair like you
got Ben you got a Joel actually talk to
Luke Davies who wrote beautiful boy
before this came out and he talked about
how you guys have like a little Aussie
compound and I had a markup on shot it
is okay yeah we all like come together
like you and Joel like chat about like
stuff so tell me about the Aussie
compound and did you recreate it for the
King yeah we had I mean not necessarily
by design but a bunch of people that I
really love but you know I you know one
of my my long-standing producers Liz
Watts was on it and had a markup or our
production designer Fiona crombie you
know that they did most of the post in
Australia as well it was as something
that's just nice about forming bonds
with people and you know working with
people again is always fun you know but
to do it with Rob Pattinson as well he's
not an Australian but yeah but it's that
recurring relationship stuff always
feels this there's a warmth in it you
know development of relationships yeah
we got to talk about Rob for you to me I
wonder what was harder the stunts the
horseback riding or not breaking when
Rob was doing no I mean that's a great
you know the first two were very
challenging I mean that to be in New
Yorker and then to want to be
convincingly authoritative on a horse
but also wielding swords was definitely
a big challenge but no there was no
design to breaking in that scene with
Rob because without spoiling it for
anyone it's so deeply insulting
everything he's saying
so if you're doing your job as an actor
you know that was a fun scene for me to
play out again and I don't wanna spoil
anything but I didn't move II call
hostels with a Christian Bale and maybe
know what do I want to say all this I
don't know like there's some similar
beats in it I don't know yeah that was
the scene where because I watched I
closely watched how he worked when I
worked with him on that movie and that
scene is the one that I can kind of
point to that he you know he would have
you do better than that way then he
would he kicked ass and like and it has
everything to do with an interior life
and not to do with uh you know like my
mind was far from how insane what Rob
was doing is it must have been fun
I mean because basically Rob's job was
just to be a jerk my face is super super
15th century French jerk I mean that's
got to be a fun thing for did you take
offense as a Frenchman like by blood and
be like no because because you could
have taken offense as a as an Englishman
so uh but you do that a purpose just to
mess with them like cats the French kid
is the English no just kidding
yeah I've got to ask this cuz he worked
for on tomatoes and everybody in the
comment section would lose it if I
didn't ask a little bit about dune and
Denny can you say it oh yes no no no but
uh you I can't wait to see it and that
was the craziest shoot my life after
this this is crazy in a totally
different way in a medieval way you know
and that was crazy in a you know Wow
look at all these things they built way
well they're wrapping me but I have one
quick thing so you guys are fresh I
think is like 77 wanna check this
morning so good job but there's this
book that we wrote at Rotten Tomatoes
called rotten movies we love where we
actually got people like Leonard Maltin
and all these really famous critics to
write about rotten movie-description
color the critics got it wrong
what's a movie you love that you would
want to write about seventy sevens where
you want to pee right yeah because if
you're it's if you're at a hundred that
means that you've just made something
that I guess everyone finds in offense
you want to be in that cone Aceves
really the art you got to have like a
little bit of dip but do you have a
rotten movie that you love like like
stepbrothers or like we step for this
run can you believe it
for like a movies dodgeball run yeah or
any of mine Rotten do you feel this
sense of achievement oh my god and then
the other cat first of all I have to say
what did they say it's okay if you only
get one minute at-bat as long as you hit
a home run so we're gonna movie that
long but girl thank you hold it in that
theme is so kind no it's really good but
is that hard knowing that like literally
your whole part cuz you obviously know
from the script like it's right this is
it I got to get it right here does that
make it more intimidating right I mean I
think it yeah it definitely can be a
little bit a little bit intimidating but
I honestly think that you know you could
either take it as like intimidation and
just like die over how nervous you are
something or just be like I'm gonna let
this feed my my character and feed my
urgency and my desire to kind of do her
justice as much as I could and and and
do is you know do the best that I could
I think it's always also like it's
intimidating going into something for
just like a few days or something and
being like I have to nail it right now
but I mean luckily I was really well
surrounded I mean David is so so
incredible to work with and you know we
had so many great discussions about
Katherine and about what she means to
him and you know how he wanted her to be
represented in the movie and everything
but and also intimidating to play a real
life character you know wanting to do
her justice and everything and she's
such a fascinating fascinating character
just like who she was and everything but
yeah it was just like a an honor
honestly above all I was so honored to
you know that they wanted me to put
wanted me to be a part of this project
and to be able to play somebody like
Katherine was just really exciting yeah
it's it's so interesting too because in
it like there's that one scene where you
and Tammy are speaking French and I know
it's Timmy's French and you're French
but he's very awkward about his four
is French sometimes like speaking it in
front of other people was he in any way
nervous about it like making sure he got
the pronunciation right well that's an
interesting part of the scene actually
is that he speaks French to her for a
second he says like a few words to her
and then he's like well we can't speak
French anymore you know we have to speak
English and she that's him kind of
trying to take control of the of the
situation of their first like real you
know one-on-one meeting and then she's
kind of like well I can't speak English
II kind of like flips it on his head
which obviously I think she can't
speaking and she just doesn't want to
you know that's her that's her being
like you're not going to just have me
like just like that I think that's a
really interesting part of the yeah
they're dynamic in like tennis like she
never gives him an inch which is really
interesting like she's very she's
observing him with with the curiosity
you know and trying to be like figure
out who this person is who she's
supposed to marry and make a life with
when all she knows of him is his his his
actions you know his his leadership as a
king and his his battles and everything
like that and the war that he's waging
against France and everything I think
that she's really trying to figure out
you know I know he's actions who is this
man yeah it's really interesting too
because the like the king or Henry the v
is such an iconic obviously because of
the Shakespeare but it's also having a
revamp because it was the basis for Game
of Thrones and you know nerds are like
oh this is like the war and so Henry is
Robb Stark's like that's Henry the
fourth and your character is like an
amalgamation of like his wife and then
like once somebody else that get by is
there any other royal person from
history that you'd want to either make a
fictionalized version of or play like a
real-life version that's a really
interesting question I mean I've always
loved Mary Antoinette and I love this
via Coppola movie I think it's so so
amazing but I think it would be really
interesting to see a story about Mary
Antoinette um after she's captured and
everything I think that you know there's
that all those letters that she wrote
and everything Oh write that screenplay
and we make this happen until amazing
a really interesting story to see but no
I think that you know when we're talking
about like taking creative licenses and
creative freedom on like on history and
kind of retelling that's what's so
interesting about this story is that you
know it's not history exactly as it was
and it's not exactly Shakespeare either
it's really David and Joel who are at
the script together taking kind of
pieces from both of those and really
putting it through their own lens and
you know they give Katherine a voice
that was not you know often afforded to
women at that time period and that's
what I love so much about reading the
script for the first time as I was like
wow you know I've never seen a a woman
in this time period speak like that and
speak with such strength and calmness
and and and Assurant Ness I think it was
really beautiful to see and it's really
you know nice to see her counsel to how
at the end of the movie compared to all
the counsel that he gets from the men
that surround him throughout the movie
yeah I think it's interesting that the
two smartest people in the room are the
two women both the woman that's next to
Falstaff and then of course yourself
next to Henry and all that my sister as
well yeah I think I think it's
definitely not a coincidence that the
the three women that we see it often in
the movie or that we see in the movie
you know though they're not there all
the time when they do appear they are
these kind of calm voices of reason I
think that's you know definitely so
that's something that David and Joel
wanted and that David you know
definitely implicated in the in the you
know the shooting and everything but
yeah I think that you know when you
compare their advice to how with like
the men around him you know their
intentions are entirely pure and I don't
think that can be said for you know all
the men in the movie that's very true
this is gonna be like a complete change
but we just recently had Kevin in studio
where we didn't read history Oh basic
lurks and the USQ university school and
of course he talked about Moose knuckles
which this jaw sorry yeah he talks about
moose jaws and he mentioned you at it
can you tell us anything cuz he's beyond
excited about it I can tell you that
much
oh you don't know anything about it I
wish I wish I could tell you something I
don't know anything I I
yeah tell him tell him to call me I mean
he's like he majors like you know this
is like you guys teaming up again with
you and Harley he said that was like one
of his favorite shoots to ever do was
because you guys were very funny to
direct it was so much fun I mean it was
like it was the best first movie that I
could have ever ever asked for I mean
you know Harley's been one of my best
friends since I was five no Kevin and
their whole family for forever and so
that was really that was the best shoot
ever and also like you know we we were
we weren't exactly our characters we
were like pretty you know pretty similar
to our characters that's how we were
like 15 and everything and so that was
just like that was the best time I would
love to work with him again that's
awesome and then the very last one as a
person born and raised in France um what
was your first reaction to Robert
Pattinson
on screen when you saw him in Venice I
thought he was great I was so I was so
excited to see his part because
obviously he's Mike he plays my brother
we don't have any scenes together so I
was like so excited to see what he was
gonna do it and everything and I thought
he was incredible I loved I loved what
he did with it
you know I think he's so yeah he's so
he's so you know frustrated like he's
just really he's pushing all the Kings
buttons I think in the perfect way and
it's exactly what we need at that time
of the movie I thought he was great but
this part it's hilarious yeah and let's
be honest like if you're gonna do a
broad like very broad French performance
just own it in every way shape or form
yeah no I love you I thought you did a
great job
[Music]
you